i pretend to be an economist hoping that
the economists will take issue
that i'm not an economist so that i can
advance gauge theoretic and field
theoretic economics
which the economics profession has
failed to acknowledge
was a major innovation that happened
approximately 25 years ago
i don't think that economists understand
what a price index is that measures
inflation nor do i think economists
understand
what a growth index uh or a
product a quantity index is
that measures gdp i think that they
don't even understand
the basics of price and quantity index
construction
and therefore they can't
possibly review uh field theoretic
economics they can't review gauge
theoretic economics
they're intellectually not in a position
to manage their own field
you talked about there's a stagnation
and growth currently
i looked at from my microeconomics
macroeconomics and college perspective
gdp doesn't seem to capture the
productivity
the full the spectrum of what i think is
as a function is a successful society
what do you think is broken about gdp
what does it need to include uh these
indices like let me let me explain what
they don't understand to begin with
sure imagine that all prices
and all quantities of output
are the same at the end of a year as
they are at the beginning
and you ask what happened during that
year was there inflation
they meandered over the course of the
year but miraculously they all came
back to exactly their values the amount
produced at the end of the year is the
same as at the beginning in every single
quantity
typically the claim would be that the
price index should be 1.0
and that the quantity index should be
1.0 that's
clearly wrong why
well it's much easier to see
with it it speaks to a fundamental
confusion that economists have they
don't understand that the economy is
curved and not flat
in a curved economy everything should be
path dependence but they view path
dependence as a problem
because they are effectively the flat
earth society of market analysis
they don't understand that what they've
called and they've actually called it
the cycling problem
is exactly what they need to understand
to advance their field
so i'll give you a very simple example
okay let's imagine that we have bob and
carol
in one hedge fund and ted and alice in
another
in both cases um the females that is
alice and carol are the chief investment
officers
and bob and ted are the chief marketing
in charge of trying to get money into
the fund and trying to get people not
to in fact remove their their money from
the funds
okay if you in fact
had uh
bob and carolyn's head analysis and both
hedge funds
were invested in assets whose prices
came back to the same levels and whose
exposures were in the same quantities
and you wanted to compensate these two
hedge funds would you compensate them
the same necessarily
what if for example uh
carol was killing it in terms of
investments every time she bought
some sort of security the price of that
security went up
okay but bob was the worst marketing
officer and as chief marketing officer
there were tons of redemptions because
bob was constantly drunk
bob was making off-color comments now
as a result at the end of the year the
fund hasn't grown in size
because even though carol was crushing
it in terms of the investments
bob was screwing up everything be and
the redemptions were legendary
so people were making money and still
pulling it out of the fund
in the other fund
alice can't seem to buy a base hit every
time she gets into a security the thing
plummets
but ted's amazing marketing skills
allowed
uh the fund to get all sorts of new
subscriptions and halted the redemptions
as people
hoped that the fund would get its act
together
okay price indices
should be how carol
and alice are compensated
and quantity indices should be how
bob and ted are compensated so
even though both funds had closed loops
that come back to the original states
what happened
during the period that they were active
tells you how people are supposed to be
compensated
now we know that whatever the increase
in the price indus
index is is compensated by a decrease
in the quantity index or conversely
because prices and quantities return to
their original values
you could have another fund where
nothing much happened there were no
redemptions no subscriptions
prices the fund remained in cash the
whole time so in that
third fund um you know let's call that
tristan is older right
that fund should have no bonuses paid
because nobody did anything but nobody
should be fired either
now the fact that the economists don't
even understand
that this is what their price and
quantity indices were intended to do
that they don't understand that you can
actually give what would be called
ordinal agents the freedom to change
their preferences
and still have something defined as a
conus cost of living adjustment they
don't even understand the mathematics of
their field
so the indices need to be able to
capture some kind of dynamics
that we have had indices that capture
these dynamics
due to the work of francois division
since 1925
but the economists have not even
understood what division's index truly
represented
what do you miss with uh with uh such
crude indices then
well you you miss the fact that you're
supposed to have a field theoretic
subject
the representative consumer should
actually be a probability distribution
on the space of all possible consumers
weighted by the probability of getting
any particular pull from the
distribution
we should not have a single gauge of
inflation like
what is that in 1973 dollars any more
than you should be able to say
it was 59 degrees fahrenheit on earth
yesterday
you